I only eat healthy food I only eat real
unprocessed food I cook almost all my
meals but why can't I lose weight I hear
your frustrations when you eat healthy
and you seem to be doing everything
right but the weight isn't budging and
you may gain even more weight it can be
extremely frustrating and you don't even
know what you're doing wrong so let's
talk about the sneaky diet saboteurs and
how these healthy foods are causing you
to gain weight trail mix or granola is a
mixture of nuts seeds dried fruits and
oats which are extremely nutritious and
convenient but they are very calorie
dense what makes matters worse is when
they are dressed with ingredients like
honey maple syrup or chocolate which
increases the calories even more one
serving should only be a quarter cup and
this has about 140 to 170 calories the
issue arises when we don't portion out
our snacks and just consume as much as
we want because hey it's healthy yes it
is nutritious yes you should add them
into your diet but be sure to portion
them out next fruit juice juicing is a
big business and it is a big trend
nowadays it is so easily available at
every coffee shop every supermarket and
everybody seems to be going on the juice
cleanse diet but is it really all that
healthy if you were to consume it every
day so let's take a look at the
breakdown for a chop our portion of cola
versus apple juice and orange juice Cola
contains 140 calories and 40 grams of
sugar which is equivalent to 10
teaspoons of sugar apple juice contains
165 calories and 39 grams of sugar which
measures 29.8 teaspoons of sugar and
orange juice contains 33 grams of sugar
which measures to 8 teaspoons of sugar
so the harsh truth is that even with no
added sugar fruit juices has almost the
same amount of sugar as Cola
whether it's 100% fruit juice or Cola if
you were to consume them regularly it is
not a good thing phryges has almost zero
fiber but it is loaded with sugar so it
is a sneaky liquid calorie drink there
will not even make you feel so much
healthier option would be to consume
their whole fruit which is packed with
fiber it is low in sugar and it will
keep you satisfied for instance a cup of
apple juice has 0.2 grams of fiber while
a whole apple contains 3.3 grams 1 cup
of orange juice has 0.5 grams of fiber
while a whole cup of freshly sliced
orange has 4.3 grams or opt for green
vegetable juice which is way lower in
sugar and it's more alkaline in nature
in comparison to fruit juices which
helps to balance the pH levels in your
body but salad dressings many people
think that by ordering a huge bowl of
salad they are eating healthy yes they
are absolutely right a huge bowl of
greens is low in calories it's packed
with fiber vitamins and minerals plus it
is very satisfying and it is hard to
overeat but what you choose to dress it
with can be a killer it can turn a
really healthy salad into a calorie bomb
so let's take a look at some of the
salad dressings and the nutrients
content in it Caesar salad 1 tbsp of
Caesar salad has 78 calories and 8 point
5 grams of fat ranch dressing packs 73
calories and 7.7 grams of fats Frenchie
dressing has 73 calories and 7.2 grams
of fat and Thousand Island has 59
calories and 5.6 grams of fat in each
tablespoon chances are you would just be
having 1 tablespoon but more like 3 to 4
tablespoons and that can add up to
almost 300 calories so the tip is to
avoid cream based dressings if you
really like your dressings then ask to
serve it on the side at least you can
control the portion a better alternative
is to go for light vinaigrette based
dressings which has half the amount of
calories
the next is my favorite superfood
avocado avocados are nutritious and
packed with healthy fats
it is the superfood used in almost
everything from making healthy ice
creams to cheesecakes
dips smoothies and even margaritas
basically anything you can think of just
know this avocado is one of the most
fattening foods and yes if you overeat
it can lead to some serious weight gain
one standard avocado has between 250 to
280 calories and 22 grams of fat
I'm not saying that you shouldn't
consume avocados but if you're watching
your weight then consume in small
quantities just have half an avocado and
pack your meals with more free foods
such as green leafy vegetables now let's
talk about coconut milk coconut milk has
been used in Asian cooking for centuries
and it used to get a really bad rap due
to its high saturated fat levels
nowadays it is regarded as a V superfood
and we're all switching to coconut milk
Hey plus it's also dairy-free so the
fatty acids in coconut milk can improve
heart health it gives you healthy skin
and hair and it can also aid with weight
loss only if you consume in moderation
full fat coconut milk is very high in
calories one cup packs a whopping 552
calories and 51 grams of saturated fats
which is way over the amount recommended
a day so the tip here is to avoid
coconut lattes of coconut smoothies that
will not do your waistline any good so
consumed in small amounts instead
consume a quarter cup to half cup
serving and only use it as add-on to
your recipes instead of having it as the
main ingredient natural sweeteners such
as honey and maple syrups are great
substitutes to refined sugars but if
consumed in large quantities they can
have the same negative effects it just
like refined sugars this include a spike
in your blood sugar levels weight gain
and even diabetes sugar is still sugar
so those really healthy desserts that
call
for one cup of maple syrup honey or
coconut sugar aren't exactly healthy you
should still consume them in small
quantities next energy bars energy bars
were once marketed to provide you with
quick energy during exercises but
nowadays they are used as a convenient
snack and even consumed as a meal
replacement energy bars are great if
you're on long endurance training such
as running a full marathon but it's not
great if you're just sitting at a desk
snacking away most energy bars are
essentially granola mixtures of nuts
seeds and dried fruits so what's holding
them together sugar oil artificial
flavors and preservatives so if you're
someone who buys lots of granola bars
and you rely on them on a daily basis it
is not doing your diet any good you
still need to consume real food
consuming whole fruits or even trail mix
is a much better option without all the
fake stuff added into it only go for
granola bars if you're on long hikes
runs or while you're traveling when it
comes to buying energy bars be sure to
flip over and look for a bar that has
less than 5 grams of fat 3 to 5 grams of
fiber less than 10 grams of sugar if
you're looking to pack on protein then
go for a bar that has at least 10 to 20
grams of protein and less than 200
calories if it's just a snack
choose a bar with as few ingredients as
possible and only made with real food
not those ingredients with some really
funky names okay and avoid bars that has
sugar listed as the first three
ingredients nowadays big brands are
cashing in on the health market by
adding gluten free to their products
let's face it even if you don't have a
wheat allergy you are more drawn to by
gluten-free products just because they
sound healthier but that is not the case
many gluten free products actually have
more calories more sugar more of that
and contains more chemicals in
comparison to the non gluten-free
versions that's because they have
replace regular flour and make up for
the loss of taste and textures by adding
other additives
if you walk it down the owl's you'll
find lots of gluten-free cookies
cupcakes bread and any other junk if
you're someone who has switched from
eating regular cookies or cupcakes to
the gluten-free versions and you're
wondering why am I not losing weight and
why do I feel crappy
that's because junk foods are still junk
foods whether or not they are
gluten-free so if you're not gluten
intolerant then just consume the normal
version and always remember in
moderation another health food that
drives me nuts are vegetable chips I
really can't stand it when they market
it as 100% vegetable chips hey they must
be good for you
wrong a serving of vegetable chips is
not even a great substitute for fresh
frozen or even canned vegetables they
will not contribute to your 5 a day one
serving of vegetables contains 25
calories and many vitamins and minerals
once the vegetables are processed into
vegetable chips either through deep
frying or baked at a very high
temperature most of the nutrients and
plant chemicals are destroyed this
leaves you with a food that is much high
in calories sodium fat and with very
little nutrients so guys consume your
vegetables whole whether it's raw
fermented or slightly cooked if you're
in the mood for salty snacks then
consume chips of any kind in small
moderate 1 ounce servings frozen yogurts
I'll have frozen yogurt instead of ice
cream because hey it's yogurt it
contains probiotics and it's great for
my gut yeah right
Oh though process yoga does contain
probiotics majority of them do not
survive long enough for you to gain the
benefits that's because the freezing
process used to make frozen yogurt may
kill some of the healthy gut bacteria
found in regular yogurt and what you
might not realize is that frozen yogurt
contains
more sugar than regular ice cream so a
half cup serving contains roughly 17
grams of sugar whereas ice cream only
has about 14 grams of sugar and when you
trick yourself into thinking that Froyo
is low-fat and it is healthy therefore
it must be good for me and I can consume
more that's when the problem starts you
tend to consume more than half cup
serving and that can pack up to 3 or 400
calories worth just like any other
desserts enjoy in small quantities if
you want to have an absolutely healthy
frozen dessert then make your own blend
up some frozen bananas with other frozen
fruits and make nice cream and the final
fruit is another of my favorite nut
butter we all know by now that nuts are
extremely calorie dense so while
consuming nut butter make you fats
well if you were to consume the entire
jar that of course if you were to
portion it out then no in fact you will
add a lot of health benefits to your
diet 1 tablespoon contains about 90
calories and 4 grams of protein so the
next time you spread it on the toast or
stir into oatmeal just be really mindful
about the calorie content and when it
comes to buying nut butter go for 100%
nut butter or only with very little
added salt avoid brands that has added
sugar added oil or any other additives
I'm not saying that you should not be
eating all these foods in fact majority
of these foods should be added into your
diet but be aware that they are not free
calories these calories can still add up
causing you to experience a plateau in
your weight loss progress or even gain
more weight so the key to not deal with
unhealthy food is to know what you're
eating and portion it out so start
practicing all these tips and
a mindful eater I hope you find all
these tips to be really useful do like
this video share this video with your
friends and let me know what other
healthy foods do you and join in the
comments below don't forget to subscribe
to my youtube channel for a lot more
fitness tips workout videos and also
healthy recipes turn on your
notification button so that you will get
notified every time I share a new video
all the best